[Music]
are you a fan of Teen Titans go and
cosplay well you better stay tuned
because we're about to show you some of
the most amazing Teen Titans go cosplay
you have ever seen
stay tuned to see a record-breaking
cosplay costume that will blow your mind
if you love Teen Titans go as much as we
do give this video a thumbs up and don't
forget to subscribe to our Channel today
we're discussing ten teen titans go
characters in real life Beast Boy you'd
think it would be impossible for someone
to look even remotely similar to Beast
Boy right if you're not familiar with
the character here are a couple of
things you should know about this green
looking superhero as the name suggests
he's actually half a beast half a boy
and his real name is actually Garfield
Logan his beast boy super power comes
from a young age when he battled an
illness that could only be cured with a
serum that later transformed him into a
superhero pretty cool right Beast Boy
has green skin pretty normal looking
hair sharp teeth and a pink and black
superhero outfit and if he was an actual
human being
this is probably what he'd look like
this cosplayer who's also a dancer
singer and a youtuber is known as Chris
villain he did a fantastic job looking
like the Beast boy from his blue-green
looking hair to his outfit this is
probably the realest beast boy
impression you will ever see the only
downside of the human beast boy is that
he probably won't be able to shape-shift
into any animal on the planet the Beast
Boy is also best friends with the next
character on our list can you guess who
it is
cyborg every beast boy needs a best
friend like cyborg cyborg also known as
Victor stone leads the life of a
superhero
that's half cybernetic
half man although this might seem
slightly unfortunate on the outside
cyborgs actually seems quite fine with
it he's a fun and very outgoing
character who even manages to find a
love interest a girl by the name of
Sarah Sims he's often seen as the
protector of the whole team and likes to
keep his best friend in check every once
in a while
sounds like a pretty cool guy don't you
think wait until you see what cyborg
would look like in real life this
cosplayers nickname is night mage and
he's known for recreating large and
mighty characters and making them look
even more powerful in real life check
out his amazing transformation into a
real-life cyborg
considering most cosplayers make their
own costumes this is a very impressive
piece of work he totally nailed cyborgs
headpiece and perhaps made it look even
better than the actual cartoon version
you definitely wouldn't want to mess
with this guy when he's in his cyborg
cosplay would you it's almost hard to
believe that such a mighty looking human
machine is so friendly and protective
but that's precisely why Teen Titans
fans love cyborg Robin Teen Titans go
wouldn't be the team they are without
their leader Robin known by his real
name Richard Grayson Robin is Batman's
BFF and he's nicknamed as the Boy Wonder
as the leader of Teen Titans Robin is
one of the bossiest characters on the
show but he does have a soft spot for
our next character can you guess who it
is
cosplaying as Robin looks like it's a
lot of fun and this deviantART user
nicknamed Takuya cosplay definitely
nailed looking like Robin Robin has
black hair a black and white mask to
cover his identity a yellow and blue
cape and a green and pink bodysuit with
a letter R on his chest
this cosplayer really did an amazing job
we bet he had a lot of fun getting into
Robins bossy character we're very
impressed by his
belt which looks to be put together by
hand much like the rest of his outfit
throughout the DC Comics universe Robin
gets replaced by several characters the
very first remains Richard Grayson
followed by Jason Todd Tim Drake
Stephanie Brown and Damian Wayne do you
have a favorite Robin ours is probably
Tim Drake also known as the Red Robin
and he even makes a slight appearance in
one of the Teen Titans go episodes
Starfire and here's the girl Robin is
obsessively crushing on throughout the
Teen Titans go series
Starfire story is quite impressive but
to keep it short she was a princess who
then became a slave then became a
warrior and is now known as a superhero
this empowering character shouldn't be
underestimated
and she's one of the most beloved Teen
Titans go characters yet this Starfire
cosplay belongs to a deviantART user
queen caffeine and it's pretty spot-on
the original Teen Titans go Starfire has
long pink hair big green eyes and a
purple outfit and it looks like this
cosplayer managed to recreate Starfire
to a tee what do you think would you add
something else Starfire is Robins love
interest and she finally becomes his
girlfriend in the movie Teen Titans
trouble in Tokyo we're very impressed
this cosplayer was even able to recreate
Starfire's
amazing eyes and put this much attention
to detail on her outfit and this
superhero princess doesn't only have the
looks she's also incredibly powerful
Starfire's power is energy absorption
energy blasts and she has a pretty
impressive combat skill but one of her
coolest powers is being able to learn a
language through physical contact
Starfire learned English during her
romance with Robin
Trigon Trigon is a very powerful demon
and the father of another eye candy
female character in Teen Titans
oh he has six eyes and he's never up to
no good
his primary mission is to make
everything negative rule the teen titan
world sounds pretty intense right well
he might be one of the most intense
looking characters we have ever seen but
his Teen Titan version is kind of cute
if you're into that sort of thing
Trigon is strong and its powers include
superhuman strength regeneration from
absolutely nothing super speed flight
telekinesis and much more he's
definitely someone you don't want to
come across but he also does have a
weakness and it seems to be his very own
arrogance which blinds his focus with
that Trigon would be a fun character to
cosplay check out the human version of
Trigon on the right this guy made it
seem that recreating a demonic character
with horns six eyes and a red body is
super easy and he's even joined by the
real-life version of his daughter whom
we will talk about next raven and he or
she is one of the most popular
characters of the whole series do you
agree with this statement let us know in
the comments who you think deserves to
be the most popular Teen Titans
character Raven trigons daughter is one
of the most interesting characters ever
she's trying to control the negativity
she got from her father but in the end
she's still on the team of these young
superheroes Raven often comes across as
sarcastic and mysterious but she stands
up for what she believes in and doesn't
give in to what her father wants to make
of her life her character is such a
popular role model you can find plenty
of Raven related cosplayers out there
but this is one of the best we've
discovered this cosplayers nickname is
sim rel and her cosplay as Raven went
viral on reddit she looks perfect in her
mysterious blue cloak blue hair and a
black outfit check out this person that
got a very awesome looking raven tattoo
what do you like or dislike about Raven
make sure you let us know in the
comments below we'd love to see your
opinion
and of this weedy character that made us
laugh out loud with her sarcasm
Blackfyre beast boy
cyborg Robin Starfire and Raven are the
main characters of Teen Titans go
but now let's have a look at some of the
characters who also deserve mentioned
Blackfyre is Starfire sister who appears
in the show for just a brief moment but
she is otherwise quite present in the DC
comics world as her name suggests
Blackfyre is a total opposite from her
sister she has long dark purple hair and
much darker although her outfit is
equally as cool her powers include super
strength stamina durability and just
like her sister she can also project
energy from her hands for a character
that doesn't really have such good
intentions as Starfire does she sounds
pretty cool
in fact she's so cool some people
decided to try out dressing up as black
fire in real life this deviantART user
is called Chi Sakai and we believe her
black fire cosplay might just be the
best one yet
check out that long purple hair and
fancy outfit that could very well look
like the real deal black fire gets her
sister in trouble on a regular basis if
you're a fan of the series you probably
remember when she dressed up Starfire as
herself pretending she wants to be her
twin
in reality this little act got Starfire
into huge trouble she means business and
so does this awesome cosplayer Tara Tara
briefly appears on a Teen Titans go
episode called terrorized that's similar
to the original plot of Teen Titans Tara
is a Latin name for land and this is why
Tara holds powers that allow her to
control the earth and minerals she turns
out to be a pretty tough character in
the DC Comics who's even able to survive
being immersed in lava her storyline
changes in every series and during her
brief appearance in Teen Titans go she
pretends to be romantic
involved with Beast Boy to get to the
team's secret files her looks make her a
pretty fun character to cosplay this
cosplayer goes by the nickname of Alice
in the TARDIS and she did a fantastic
job at portraying what Terra might look
like in real life Terra has long blonde
hair a black top yellow shorts and brown
boots in teen titans Terra raises a lot
of fan theories that she was a very
misunderstood character who didn't know
how to make friends and just wanted a
place to belong she's probably one of
the least favourite characters on the
show but that doesn't mean that she
doesn't have fans who want to recreate
her looks in real life well Terra wasn't
the only character people have mixed
feelings about Ravager much like Terra
Blackfyre and Batman
Ravinder is just a minor character in
Teen Titans go but she comes with such
an iconic look we just had to add her to
this list
Ravinder is one of our favorite
characters from the series and although
she has a minor part in Teen Titans go
she's one of the most powerful
characters ever her real name is Rose
Wilson and she's a martial arts expert
who's also skilled at combat she has
many enhanced abilities that make her a
super soldier and she has the incredible
power of precognition which allows her
to predict the moves of her opponents
her unique look consists of long white
hair an eyepatch covering one of her
eyes and an orange black and blue outfit
a cosplayer who goes by the name of
Megan Coffey did an amazing job at
recreating a real-life Ravager
check out this excellent picture of her
holding to fire swords like a complete
pro what do you think does this compare
to the DC Comics version Ravager might
not be a very lovable character and
while she might not be on the good side
she is hilarious
with her witty remarks and sarcasm
Batman alright alright
we can't talk about Teen Titans without
mentioning Batman can we he's very close
to
robbing but he very briefly makes a few
appearances in Teen Titans go one of the
episodes includes him getting tied in
the face by Robin Batman is a very
fascinating character and one of the
most popular DC Comics superheroes ever
you can probably imagine how many Batman
cosplayers are out there right but
there's only one that was able to set an
incredible cosplay record
the Guinness gamers edition 2017 showed
off a unique Batman cosplay suit made by
an Irish special creature effects expert
Julian check Lee this amazing suit
consists of 23 brilliant gadgets that
include video screens projectors a UV
lamp bat cams and more here's an even
more epic fact about this creation some
of these gadgets were made using a 3d
printer how awesome is that
we bet there are a lot of cosplayers out
there who would love to get their hands
on this awesome suit
speaking of Batman did you know that
Batman is an actual city in Turkey it
was named after an ancient unit of
measure and had unfortunately nothing to
do with this iconic superhero do you
have a favorite character from the DC
Comics let us know in the comments below
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button for more stories like this if
you're into superheroes check out 10
Disney Princesses reimagined as
superheroes see you in the next video
[Music]
you
[Music]